when you're at the controls of a giant
franchise you can't please everybody and
this seems to go double for Star Wars
fans Disney CEO Bob Iger took a
philosophical approach to fans
dissatisfaction with the sequel trilogy
during a conversation with Variety at
the Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
premiere Iger acknowledged that while
the creative minds behind the series
tried to be mindful of what fans wanted
they were also aware of the fine line
between fanservice and simple pandering
we respect fans of Star Wars that's
really important to us too Lucasfilm to
the franchise we do the best job we
possibly can
agar expressed his own satisfaction with
the job that his filmmakers had done on
the sequels including JJ Abrams who as
the co-writer and director of the rise
of Skywalker had the unenviable task of
bringing the nine film Skywalker saga to
a close in a way that would be true to
all of the movies that came before while
still giving fans everything they wanted
and telling his own unique story we've
done a really good job of threading that
needle walking that fine lives you know
because we respect our fans but we don't
over react to it either brace yourself
for a shock many fans and critics
disagree one of the common complaints
about rise of Skywalker has concerned
its willingness to indulge in fanservice
at the expense of its story which can be
seen as course-correction away from the
daring narrative choices made in the
series previous instalment the last Jedi
while that film was one of the best
reviewed in the entire series
it's supremely divided fans some of whom
now feel that Abrams has swung too far
back in the opposite direction
another pervasive gripe that rises
Skywalker was illustrative of the fact
that the trilogy as a whole lacked a
unified vision which may be why there
has recently been talk of future Star
Wars movies straying away from the
trilogy format Lucasfilm president
Kathleen Kennedy suggested as much
during an interview with the Los Angeles
Times the weekend before the release of
episode 9 she said I think focusing on
single films gives us a more open-ended
view of storytelling and doesn't lock us
into this three act structure we're not
going to have some finite number and fit
it into a box we're really going to let
the story dictate
that Uyghur however implied that her
comments should be taken with a grain of
salt oh I don't know about that I think
she and I have said well maybe trilogies
are too hard so maybe we'll make one
film and then a sequel well we don't
know of course it's likely that some
observers will take this as yet further
evidence that the stewards of Star Wars
lack a clear vision for the property but
even the staunchest critics would have
to agree that the house of mouse hasn't
done everything wrong so I'm still in
come on
in fact one thing has gone very very
right for Disney star wars endeavors of
late the Mandalorian the Disney Plus
series that has drawn critical raves
helped amass millions of subscribers for
the nascent streaming service and
launched a bona fide pop-culture icon in
the child the adorable character better
known to fans and the world at large as
baby Yoda Uyghur admitted that while he
obviously had high hopes for the series
success even he was blindsided by its
rapturous reception well I think it
would be wrong for me to say I knew
exactly how everybody would react
because it's been huge but I did have a
strong sense that it was a character
people who are going to love perhaps the
Mandalorian could help provide some
guidance for Disney and Lucasfilm brass
on how to effectively engage fans going
forward that is beyond put baby Oda and
everything which we honestly wouldn't
have much of a problem with season 2 of
the series is currently in production
and if creator showrunner Jon Favreau is
able to keep fans hooked
Iker and Kennedy would do well to take a
good hard look at how they could apply
some of his mando magic to future Star
Wars films I gotta get one of those of
course they've also reached out for a
little help from across the hall in a
development which these Star Wars
faithful have simply got to be pumped
about it was announced in September that
Marvel boss Kevin Feige who has had just
a little bit of success in developing
beloved properties for the big screen to
the utter delight of fans has been
tapped to help develop a new Star Wars
picture
well we won't see the fruits of this
arrangement for quite some time that's
okay
agar has made it clear that Disney won't
be rushing any new Star Wars flicks to
market after the rights of Skywalker but
will instead place the property on a two
or three year hiatus while the direction
of the franchise's worked out we'll see
about that all of which is to say that
while the sequel trilogy main
not have been exactly what everybody
hoped for the future of Star Wars still
looks reasonably bright also it must be
said the mouse house may not have
fielded a perfect trio of films but hey
they were better than the prequels right
I'm not sure I understand
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell suit don't miss
a single one
[Music]